all right one of the great Mysteries of
the Apple watch have you guys ever
wondered the question is can you get 24
stand hours actually can you get more
than 24 sand hours so a stand hour is
pretty simple right you just stand up
for 60 seconds out of every hour and
your Apple watch can detect that you're
standing and give you credit for that
stand hour so 24 stand hours is already
going to be really hard theoretically if
you fly backwards a few time zones and
stand up for every single hour then you
will add up to over 24 stand hours in a
day so that's exactly what I did so I
just got on a flight to California which
is three hours behind East Coast time
and I made sure I was getting those
stand hours in yes I did miss one but I
stood up every single other hour
starting at midnight and every hour on
the plane which was really annoying but
I did it for the cause 22 23 24 and then
Moment of Truth this is what 25 stand
hours looks like confirmed it works I'm
so tired